قيمه تسويقيه ودعائيه كبيره يمتلكها النجم
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو المنضم حديثا
لنادي النصر السعودي مكاسب نادي النصر
مشاهدينا بدات تظهر سريعا حيث ارتفع عدد
متابعي صفحه النادي في الانستغرام من 800
الف متابع الى سبعه ملايين
5700,000,000 متابع وهم يشكل اكثر من تسعه
اضعاف خلال اربعه ايام فقط كذلك فتويتر
وصل عدد مشاهدات تغيير اعلان الرسمي عن
التعاقد مع اللاعب الى ثلاثه وسبعين مليون
مشاهده حتى الان ماذا عن مبيعات القمصان
الجماهير النصراويه ومحبون اللاعب
مشاهدينا لم يبقوا قميصا واحدا في متجر
النادي الارقام تشير الى وصول حجم
المبيعات الى مليونير حتى الان وفقا
لصحيفه الاقتصاديه شروط العربيه مشاهدينا
في المتجر كشافات عندنا قميص اللاعب من
المتجر خلال 48 ساعه واصلت قائمه الانتظار
الى ثلاثه ايام النجم البرتغالي يعتبر
اكبر المؤثرين على مستوى العالم في تطبيق
الانستغرام بنصف مليار متابع سته وثمان
منهم في المئه مصنفون كمتابعين نشيطين اما
اما عن مستوى التفاعل مع منشوراته عبر
التطبيق فيبلغ متوسط الاعجابات سته ملايين
ومئه الف اعجاب مقابل خمسه ملايين
و400,000 تعليق للمنشور الواحد وفقا
لهيبودر هذه الارقام مشاهدينا عكست بشكل
مباشر على قيمتي منشوراته الارقام تبين ان
رونالدو يحصل على مليونير دولار مقابل كل
منشور الامر الذي جعله يكسب نحو مئه او
135 مليون دولار في عمي 20 واحد وعشرين هم
يشكل ثلاثه اضعاف قيمه عقده مع مانشستر
يونايتد رونالدو وكوكاكولا ابرز الشواهد
على قيمه الدعائيه الكبيره النجمه غالي
قبل سنه 90 وفي دي المؤتمرات المؤتمرات
الصحفيه ازاحه كريستيانو زجاجتي كوكاكولا
من الطاوله واستبدلهما بعبوتي ماء هذا
التصرف مشاهدينا تسبب بخساره شركه
المشروبات الغازيه اربعه مليارات دولار